[Musique]
lahoud cpa
salut c'est d'homme on va sortir un
nouveau podcast à chaque semaine donc
pour nous suivent ce poème de youtube
line page facebook puisque fini dans
l'application balado dans ton téléphone
tu peux aussi commenté les personnes que
tu souhaites conçoivent ce podcast puis
sa base aérienne en outre bois bienvenue
chez nous merci de me recevoir
merci à toi de venir ici puis aussi
merci à toi de considérer le web dans ta
démarche parce que je pense qu'il ya en
considérant le web comme ça sarr
intéresse les jeunes au moins à suivre
la démarche et ça c'est cool pour les
partis politiques c'est un grand défi
parce que traditionnellement pour parler
de nos propositions par les données de
nos pour faire nos campagnes électorales
contournement les partis politiques
parlent et se parlaient surtout et
seulement aux médias traditionnels et
donc parce que les habitudes des gens
aussi pour s'informer c'était à la fin
de la journée d'écouter le téléjournal
le matin d'ouvrir le journal ses
habitudes le sont en train de changer ça
plein avantage ça permet à plein de
monde d'avoir des tribus noires les
exprimer soit c'est un point positif
mais c'est un défi aussi non pas aux
grisons comment on va rejoindre les gens
pour leur parler de nos idées puis nous
on est bien qu'au 5e surtout pour dix
ans les jeunes je m'inclus la bande à
gégé 28 ans pour parler à ma génération
faut sortir justement dans des méthodes
traditionnelles de communication parce
que sinon on parle pas à tout le monde
et même loin de l'om jacky on ne parle
pas une majorité on peut télévision le
bandeau du national 1 bien fait donc si
on se si on s'en tient aux métiers
traditionnels on parle essentiellement à
des gens plus âgés
cc c'est triste c'est ça puis ces gens
là c'est souvent les gens qui
qui ont une mentalité assez strictes à
série gilles as établie avec les années
en fait pas très malléable où s intègre
facilement intérêts sable mais c'est
sans aucun doute on est bien conscient
puis ça a toujours été comme ça les gens
qui sont les plus favorables à nos idées
une traditionnellement piste encore
comme ça aujourd'hui c'est les plus
jeunes donc tu as raison que pour un
parti comme nous pour quelqu'un comme
moi c'est encore plus important parce
que si on veut rejoindre les gens qui
sont les plus intéressés par des enjeux
comme l'environnement t il faut sortir
des casses traditionnels parce que sinon
on est à côté de la track complètement
l'on manque complètement notre shop
si on reste dans des formats classiques
skieur est ce qu'il ya un côté négatif
aux médias sociaux par rapport à la
politique
oui c'est pas juste des bonnes nouvelles
regardez ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis avec donald charmant avec
l'émergence du phénomène des fêtes news
les médias traditionnels ont des défauts
ils sont souvent rigides ils sont
souvent
ils sont souvent voilà ils sont rigides
dans la forme dans la forme et à une
rigueur et une crédibilité associés à
ces médias la sema besoins qui sont
parfaits moi même des fois je suis très
critique de leur travail mais au moins
il ya quand même une rigueur
journalistique des des codes et des
normes
il ya des pratiques établies pis les
médias qui sont établis ce parce qu'ils
ont une certaine crédibilité dans ce
sens pas vraiment qu'ils sont vraiment
pas parfait c'est pour ça que je dis
mais au moins dans une certaine au
niveau de crédibilité
le défi avec le web et les médias
sociaux c'est que le étant donné que
tout le monde peut s'improviser
journaliste tout le monde peut se dire
être un média comme je dis ça des bons
côtés ça permet à des gens qui avait pas
de tribune d'en avoir une soit pour la
démocratie
une bonne nouvelle en même temps ça pose
le défi de la crédibilité
comment on s'assure que le débat public
il reste minime allemand basé sur des
faits mais comme tensions à venir
une tuerie aux états unis c'est pas vrai
c'est un roc c'est une fabrication qu'on
le fait un alex jones aux états unis
mais là c'est ton des baillis pu sur
c'est quoi nos idées c'est que nous
voilà il a débridé est complètement
faussé parce qu'il s'articule autour de
mensonge donc pas d'interprétations
différentes des faits ou par un mensonge
complet
comment tu fais pour débattre dans une
démocratie si on se qualifie on s'était
attirée par ce genre de propos là aussi
ça ça crée un cercle vicieux aussi
pluton fil d'actualités devient
complètement débile moi j'ai même on
peut le voir moi des fois j'ai
l'impression
parce que je me tiens avec du monde
assez politisé assez impliqué je peux
avoir l'impression que certains enjeux
sont sur les lèvres de tout le monde je
traverse sortante vraiment dans ma bulle
à moi puis on a tous nos oeufs lapins
nains complice elop peut-être un autre
des défis les médias sociaux c'est
comment on fait pour avoir une prison
vers nation
général à l'échelle de la nation à
l'échelle du québec
ouais comment on fait pour pas que tous
restés enfermés dans le fond dans nos
petites bulles de médias sociaux parce
que ça nous empêche des fois aussi
d'être en contact avec d'autres idées
exemple en contact avec d'autres types
de personnes et l'enregistrement c'est
que tous ont un peu enfermé dans nos
bulles de communication je suis pas sûr
que globalement c'est une avancée m
c'est clairement un défi on reviendra
pas avant les médecins ont retourné
pendant longtemps mais ça pose la
question comment on fait pau malgré ces
nouvelles réalités là avant des débats
démocratiques qui sont larges qu'ils
sont sains
oui plus de gens peuvent s'exprimer mais
où on s'entend sur les faits puis on est
encore capable de se parler de ce polar
à la polarisation est pire que l'été est
ce que ça crée un clivage puis un rivage
plus importants à cause de sa semence et
ses bulles qui est concret les gens vont
se regrouper nos bras ou de l'autre par
les autres d'autres sans vraiment changé
c'est une bonne question c'est beaucoup
une question de perception de certains
un discours qui dit ce qu'est ce qui a
tendance à être un peu je pense
nostalgique dans le temps on avait
tellement des beaux débats étaient
tellement c'est générationnel commencé
on avait toujours des conduites et la
caricature mais ces défauts sont un
petit peu ce qu'on entend pas sûr qu'on
peut idéaliser le passé d'erreur daltin
jusque dans le temps ses socios 2 % des
gens dans une société en un pour cent
des jeunes sociétés qui ont accès à des
tribunes médiatiques c'est l'élite cdh
et jean louis plus éduqués mais
globalement ça veut dire que plein de
gens à qui on donne pas la parole
non est-ce qu'on peut blâmer les médias
sociaux d'avoir permis de donner la
parole à ceux qui l' qui peut pas la
prendre
wen avoir démocratisé l'accès à certains
espaces publics
je pense qu'on peut pas l'on peut pas
regretter ça est-ce que ça a contribué à
polariser peut-être je pense que des
instructions en train de monter dans des
feuilles des fois des sourires sur ses
plates formes là des lieux des
phénomènes de
discret mais moi je serais plutôt comme
nuances sur cette question là parce que
je ça m'énerve le discours trop
nostalgique pas dans le bon vieux temps
tout le monde c'est fou quand on se
rappelle l'épopée sont québécoises n'ont
jamais été autant éduquer jamais autant
de gens qui sont à l'université le
niveau de vie s'est largement amélioré
ya beaucoup de gens que beaucoup plus de
gens qui savent lire écrit aujourd'hui
qu'il allait pendant l ogre a par
exemple
donc quand même se rappeler sautez donc
pas mon genre il est rageant reviendrait
pas dans le soi disant bon vieux temps
limite un psychologue de disco aussi d
ailleurs il faut aussi ailleurs ils font
ce qu en se comparant en réalité théo
québec
des fois qu'on écoute les radios les
médecins ont l'impression que ça va dans
ma réalité c'est bon vivre il ya encore
place à amélioration vraiment sauf que
des endroits où ce que j'aimerais vis la
planète y en a beaucoup d'autres que je
me tairai je serai mieux là bas c'est
bien une belle qualité de vie on a des
services publics qui ont été magané d'un
derby mais globalement quand même 11
écoles fonctionnent nos hôpitaux malgré
tout fonctionne évidemment je fais
partie des gens qui disent que ça
pourrait mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas
dans une situation de catastrophe
à une exception près c'est sur la
question environnementale est le moins
cher est alarmé ces mots soient
environnement je pense qu'il faut que le
droit de voir pascal ôter les dans son
sombre ça va vraiment pour un thé dans
d'autres domaines je pense qu'on a
réussi quand même à au québec a gardé
des bons services plutôt bonne qualité
10 mai sur la place d'environnements
jeux d'été c'est la catastrophe assurée
par an un peu les pistes de solution par
rapport à la question environnementale
en ce moment chez que moi monsieur
maintenant par mon nouveau style de vie
jusqu'à s'impliquer dans l'est dans ces
choses là pfff c'est une question que je
me pose sans arrêt parce que quand tu
réalises toutes les démarches sont
entreprises par exemple pour éliminer
les spas et des débords paix s'est bien
démené les pas des bars mais des enjeux
beaucoup plus grands que ceux qui sont
même pas abordé fait que c'est quoi les
pistes de solution pour la situation
environnementale surtout au québec
considérant que ces locaux
un impact si on commence par le plus
générale je dirais que c'est sûr que la
question des changements climatiques
c'est le gros défi les changements
climatiques je pense que ce seront les
faits là dessus le 1
il faut se dépêcher il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite que ce qu'on fait en
ce moment nos objectifs de réduction
dans un phare au québec c'est des
objectifs très timide puis on est quand
même entré des ratés on est prêts on est
en train de rater donc quelque chose qui
va pas mais moi je pense qu'au québec
ont une responsabilité
il ya des gens en ce moment il ya des
sociétés où les gens se rendent compte
que 60 70 % de leur électricité et de
sources non renouvelables dans des
centrales thermiques des centrales au
charbon du nucléaire et l'aï dit ce
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
nous on a déjà eu l'immense privilège
par une ironie par un beau hasard de
l'histoire et la géographie
ouais on a de l'électricité renouvelable
en quantité phénoménale 15% je pense de
l'état même à 98 au niveau des lectrices
donc on essaie comme si on devait déjà
sur une gamme de 4 comparé déjà les murs
avec une royal flush on a le support on
s'est fait dit les bonnes cartes par le
hasard de l'histoire
un hacker ça nous donne une d'autant
plus grande responsabilité de un prêt
nous on a tout pour le faire
on ne tourne le dos de l'électricité
renouvelable en masse on
donc on a un avantage il faut ça pour
moi on ne ne reste qu'une responsabilité
par rapport à ceux qui n'ont pas un des
leaders de la face cette transition
alors plus rapidement dans des temps
l'avant plan ça veut dire électri les
transports très rapidement augmenter nos
services de transport en commun les
rendent aussi plus abordable
ça veut dire améliorer le transport
inter régionales parce qu'au québec
oh oui on d'un grand territoire même des
problèmes qu'on a c'est que ce
territoire là ils croyaient été
complètement déstructurée
on a pu c'est impossible de se déplacer
sur le territoire du québec
sans voiture de manière efficace fait
plus trop en gaspésie à nos yeux
moi moi je viens de la région de tête
froide quand j'étais jeune pilote ça
fait pas car ça fait quelques années à
peine
jaillet jeter passée s'était passé pour
moi prendre l'autobus à montréal qui ne
me rendre ma famille cet autobus l'oeil
4 ou 5 1 ont été fermées donc à une
époque on devrait entrer d'augmenter le
transport est un régional où le diminuer
je dis pas qu'on a été dans le statu quo
on la diminuant le diviseur ça aucun
sens cela n'a aucun sens a su rester du
monde allait travailler en région c'est
pour commencer à tirer le monde vers les
régions tout c'est pisser majeur le
transport si tu peux pas de rendre en
région en facilement convaincre auprès
des jeunes familles des licences talent
ils n'ont juste pas ouvrir non
définitivement les individus là dedans
si je comprends aussi l'apport de deux
les partis politiques puissent
gouvernement à amédée mesure mais je
pense aussi les individus en soit aussi
leur chemin à faire au niveau de
diminuer leur consommation mais de
viande par exemple de la manière qu'ils
se comportent dont s qui sait où en fait
qui est la plus grande différence cette
affaire est ce que c'est aux entreprises
que c'est au gouvernement ce que vous
individus à faire le bout de chemin
c'est tous ces personnes en même temps
la réponse facile c'est sûr que c'est
tout ça en même temps c'est à dire que
si chacun d'entre nous ont fait des
efforts dans notre vie personnelle mais
que le réseau de transport en commun
inexistant ou pas fonctionnel ça servira
à rien de faire des gestes individuels
inverse s'il ya des gestes que l'état
post 1
mais que les gens utilisent pas ces
services là on est dans la même
situation mais pour tout dire
moi je pense que les habitudes
individuelles ça se change dans la
mesure où c'est facile est possible avec
moi si
si j'avais à choisir je dirais que la
priorité c'est sur des gestes collectif
c sûr des gestes structure en mars que
prenons le recyclage là et quand même là
c'est quand même ça fait en à peine une
génération au québec on est passé de
tout mettre à la poubelle mais je dis ça
pour ça à la cueillette sélective dans
la plupart des endroits où il ya bon du
recyclage des matières résiduelles
normal puis même de plus en plus du
court passage qui en quelques années on
est passé de 1 à l'autre qui vous allez
vous allez dans les écoles aujourd'hui
du québec pour les jeunes qu'on éduque
aujourd'hui cette distinction labour le
compost la récupération des poubelles je
veux dire c'est complètement acquis de
son évidente mais le problème c'est que
si je peux si vous le savez par exemple
mais je me rends au québec
90% du verre qu'on met au risque large
sera mise à l'étude et déjà ils ont
changé leurs habitudes les ont changé
leurs comportements ont évolué mais le
système de gestion du recyclage est
tellement tout croche qu'on n'est même
pas capable de le recycler le vin relevé
aux poubelles fait que l'on fait croire
aux gens un camp avec leurs petits
gestes qui vont changer le monde on leur
dit c'est ta responsabilité toi tronçon
un bon citoyen on a même des fois il ya
peu de culpabilité avec ça
mais à l'autre bout on n'est même pas
capable de livrer la marchandise noté
moi je veux bien qu'on fasse des efforts
pige en fait on doit faire comme
individu mais moment donné ça servira à
rien si l'état le gouvernement joue pas
son rôle pied pas au leader parce que
sinon les petits gestes ils vont
plafonner vite que l'exemple du
recyclage que je viens de prendre ce
très bel exemple parce qu'on est tous
ceux que l on reste qu'on est bon au
québec
- c'est vrai que individuellement des
bons mais collectivement en notre
système de recyclage y touche
moi j'ai une scène qui me revient
toujours quand on compare le seul député
à québec dans mon kahn qui jetait sur
mon patio qui j'étais avec mon coloc que
nos amis fils puis dans notre containers
de recyclage
en fait il y avait 1 une partie poubelle
une partie recyclage puis moi j'y allais
toujours tout j'ouvre est le panneau
correctement et on était sur notre
passion on a regardé le shard eu de
poubelles passé comme ça quand tu es
noir au complet pile compotée félon ont
capoté on comprenait pas nous on avait
fait on prenait la peine de le faire
visiter et et je veux dire c'est plus
simple de tout prendre pituchos et aux
poubelles ti c'est plus simple de faire
ça sauf que on prenait à peine de le
faire dans notre quotidien
le fait notre choix c'est une belle
image
le casque pour illustrer le problème
qu'ont auxquels on fait face
actuellement ont formé énormément dans
l'emphase sur les gestes individuels
mais on oublie que tout ça repose en
dernière instance la sueur des choix
collectifs devant les jours avant les
bonnes institutions le bon modèle
économique pour que ça fonctionne sinon
ça plafonne me paraît inutile ça faisait
qu'on arrive est à la limite de ce que
comme ils savaient que les gens
sentaient plus à un ou à leur fait
copions leur fac roller fait gronder les
choses
moi j'ai par rapport aux questions
environnementales c'est sûr qu'il faut
que je pose la question je peux de
mettre dans l'embarras mais c'est un peu
pour ceux qui on est ici dans cette
conversation l'a été en parle beaucoup
de l'industrie du transport le sud
transports en termes de gaz à effet de
serre c'est 13% des émissions globales
sur la planète alors que l'industrie de
la viande est de 14% et dans l'industrie
de la viande selon ces cyclos d'être
14% l'industrie du transport qui inclut
le transport de viande
tu parles des changements qui sont
faciles à faire pour le pour les gens
moi d'arrêter de prendre mon de ma
voiture de mayence est beaucoup plus
sain
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour moi
que de jeu changé mon alimentation
c'est qu'elle est la langue que toi dans
un an 1,1 québec et utopie tu aurais tu
verrais bien des gestes versant comme
une commission moi personnellement j'ai
été élevé dans je pense d'une manière
assez semblables la plupart des jeunes
québécois 700 heures repas c'est quoi
c'est la viande aux légumes puis patates
lui répond et donc et moi j'ai grandi
dans une famille comme ça et donc quand
je me suis mis à me faire à manger c'est
comme ce que je fais pas ça s'est
généralisé comme idée pis pour moi un
repas fallait que la viande est à paul
déjeuner et encore et encore encore le
week-end et depuis quelques mois je fais
ce travail là de doké faut que je
réalise ma confirmation du support rendu
à un moment où je me dis j'en mange pas
pour plusieurs raisons
mais déjà bien conscient que gens
consommaient trop vite des gens
consommaient moins je pense que c'est
important que je pense que globalement
c'est à ça qu'il faut aspirer plus loin
qu'avec ceux de l'ass et là dedans qu'on
est dans une d2 il faut diminuer la
consommation de viande est quand même là
il a diminué progressivement mais on le
sait le que d'un point de vue climatique
donne environnementale
ce n'est pas soutenable et jeudi on
n'est pas encore rendu au moment où tous
les petits indiens dont comment manger
autant dire que les 3,5 millions
d'américains la gelée jusqu'en il d'un
point de vue économique
à quoi ça ressemble le le prospect
d'avoir de réduire la consommation de
viande pour toutes les agricultures tout
le reflet cultivateurs mais le mot clé
pour ces affaires là c'est transition il
faut penser de manière transitoire est
même là mais c'est la même chose pour
l'utilisation du pétrole dans nos
transports le jour où plus d'un coup on
utiliserait pétrole pour se transporter
il faut par contre dès demain matin
autre hommage le mot tradition veut pas
dire pelleter point par des bombes dans
son désir pour commencer tout de suite
parce que ça va être un processus
relativement je pense que pour les le
changement des habitudes alimentaires
c'est un peu similaire il faut commencer
la sensibilisation nous c'est la demande
tranquillement c'est beaucoup aussi j'ai
l'offre qui est est dans une dynamique
de transition pour ses agrumes cesser
ces agriculteurs l'homme s'est élevé à
halle et le mot clé ici c'est sert
qualification il faut accompagner ce
monde là haut dans toutes les industries
qui vont être affectés par la transition
écologique m'ont accompagné les gens ce
qu on va s'en dire le l'état de la
planète ne s'est pas legault qui
travaille chez olymel à saint-hyacinthe
qui ont apporté les conséquences de ces
pas du tout pas du tout c'est pas la
faute des agriculteurs qui fait la force
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
qui travaillent pas eu à payer la
facture
c'est un peu de la faute à personne dans
un sens que tout le monde contribue à un
système puis on est tous ou outrance à
certaines ou le directeur resterait
longtemps que je t en fait je suis
d'accord avec toi quand tu dis une
responsabilité partagée
il ya quand même aussi des entreprises
des intérêts qui ont des plus grandes
qu'elles tiers des le tiers de la viande
en épicerie qui est jeté à chaque
semaine tu considères ceux déjà comme
étant un tireur 1 33% qui pourrait
complètement enlevé est ce qu'on va
laisser tant dans les industries aussi
kiki qui veulent pas le changement parce
que le justement cela profite
ils voudront pas que sasha nom et
surtout quand on sait que les grandes
pétrolières finances activement des
études pour nier l'existence de
changement climatique moi je veux bien
qu'on dise aux gothiques trois pick up
qui pourrait n'avoir juste en place
c'est pas lui qui est autant de
responsabilités que l'immigrant rand
corporation pétrolières qui c'est qui
dans le fond fausse le débat public
depuis des années en finançant des gens
qui nient les changements climatiques t
pour faire attention
pour conclure sur ta question ph au
nouveau la viande je pense que ce soit
c'est une question de transition de
s'assurer que l'on sait pas les régions
du québec sont à surveiller pour ce un
prix trop élevé noir ni les régions et
les travailleurs les travailleuses dans
ces industries dont ses portes
la faute puis ont pas porté le prix de
cette tension
c'est vrai aussi pour les gens qui
travaillent dans le secteur pétrolier
donc c'est la priorité numéro un pour
qu'avec ça c'est toujours difficile de
parler en termes de nîmes héros au
témoin marrante l'égalité hommes femmes
ou environnementaux tout simplement de
choisir je vais refuser le droit de
priorité dans ce sens là donc dans
l'absolu ça pour la prochaine rencontre
pour la prochaine campagne
ça va être aucun sens mais trop car on
va avoir un plan de transition chiffrés
ambitieux mais pragmatique donc réaliste
qui va expliquer comment on la voit
cette tension au québec dans l'est
essentiellement les dix prochaines
années avec des objectifs de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre des moyens
chiffrés pour atteindre ses cibles et là
c'est un beau et des belles cibles de
réductions encore faussé la volée les
moyens d'atteindre ses cibles donc oui
pour la prochaine campagne ça va être ça
va être vraiment important mais c'est
sûr que dans l'absolu il ya beaucoup de
chose d'important beaucoup de
l'environnement
c'est décourageant aussi quand on voit
que on a des voisins qui vont un sens
complètement inverse je pense on en
ontario justement qui viennent de
d'enlever les crédits pour les eaux a
lâché des autos électriques l'avait pas
un 12 métal hard des crédits s'est
enlevé 7 10 créént et on essaie d'aller
dans une direction mais aucun autre au
pis si des fois faut pas trop des fois
faut pas trop regarder autour
pressenti sa propre affaire parce que on
n'a aucun contrôle avec ce salaire en
allant tourner ou pis si si par exemple
tu réussi à créer une société qui
devient ultra positive qui peut devenir
un modèle pour les autres qui regardent
autorités aux etats-unis ce pauvre
actuellement nouveautés comme si le e
book exactement puis beaucoup de monde
qui ont peu voté aussi ces gens le
voient des sociétés qui montre une
alternative qui est viable qui quittent
effectivement leur peut dire que ça va
leur donner envie de le faire ou non si
on peut pas attendre après les autres
champs à quoi bon
il faut pour se concentrer sur ce qu'on
a du pouvoir sinon va déprimer première
chose puis on fera rien dit mais en même
temps tu vois ton qui reconnaît à peu
près ou à moitié l'existence des
changements climatiques
c'est facile de le pointer du doigt
comme chambre soit celle de dire à
regarder comment ce été réhabilité en
même temps si josé romao nous aussi au
canada un premier ministre qui dit qui
reconnaît l'existence du changement
climatique qui se rendent devant tous
les caméras d'en faire une grande
priorité
mais dans les faits ils viennent
nationalisé par l'epad en alberta au
coup de tonnerre du presque 4 milliards
d'euros
donc quand quelqu'un qui est juste
complètement
il y aura puisé les changements
climatiques n'existe pas que je dise ça
existe c'est poli mais richesses vont
aller dans ce sens inverse des
niaiseries quelqu'un qui dit qui croit à
la science mais agit contre un qui est
le plus fou même question grâce au
général c'est parce qu'il fait on quand
tu dis que tu crois la science mais pj
en toute connaissance de cause à
l'encontre de ce que la science de 10
faire la malle
c'est pire puis on devrait juger encore
plus durement
peu de gens quelqu'un qui est au courant
pas vraiment et définitivement
définitivement si on si on parle plus
concrètement de québec solidaire
quels sont les objectifs à court à moyen
long terme du parti sur un échelle de
combien de temps nous on est reparti en
croissance grandi au cours de la
dernière année on est là dedans on est
dans une dynamique de croissance où on
veut avancer pour la prochaine élection
c'est la preuve c'est la première étape
pour nous la cedh augmenter de manière
importante le nombre de députés on peut
plus se contenter d'aller chercher un
député par élections
après dix ans on est rendu ailleurs on a
une étape à franchir dans les bains
conscient puis moi je m'en suis fait une
objectif personnel aussi on peut plus se
contenter de ce rythme-là de croissance
faut grandir plus vite
après ça est-ce qu'on va grandir un peu
beaucoup passionnément
c'est dur à dire c'est le monde qui vont
décider et et regarde les dernières
élections municipales
tout le monde disait que c'était joué
d'avancé que denis coderre
confortablement
regardons dénonce élections fédérales où
on disait c'est le npd tout droit en
troisième position aucune chance
regardez ce qui s'est passé donc j'ai
toujours des surprises acquise en plus
compliqué allez on sait comme s'est
décuplé le truc dont on y danse jamais
jamais perdre l'élan de drogue qui a
cessé depuis
j'étais au grand prix de trois rivières
deux semaines puis je parlais à michel
barrette me disait la pratique c'est
comme la course automobile sais pas où
tu pars c'était au début même sait pas
où est ce que tu es et à la ligne
d'arrivée c est ce qu on va se retrouver
le 1er octobre au soir avec une dizaine
de députés
est-ce qu'on va se retrouver avec une
vingtaine de députés une trentaine
trentaine de titres que vous commencez à
l'opposition officielle est ce qu'on se
ramasse au pouvoir c'est c'est dur a dit
opter avoir avoir bébé qui était chip
mais une fois que j'ai appris rapidement
en politique partisane première année
c'est que pour que tu te concentres sur
les affaires que tu contrôles
quand merde faire du mauvais sang sur
les sondages sur la manière dont les
médias couvrent tu deviens fou parce que
tu vois juste les problèmes tu es
constamment insatisfaits petit de vie et
great villefranche et les otages sont
mal en point il veut rien dire
présentement ça va tellement changé dans
la campagne que moi je me concentre sur
les trucs sur lesquels j'ai dû contrôler
ça c'est vrai dans mon travail de député
c'est vrai dans mon travail en interne
québec solidaire se concentrer sur les
affaires contre le boss est la meilleure
manière de devenir footballeur je me
concentre sur les enfants sur lequel
j'ai une prise c est ce que nos
candidats
est ce que moi je suis prêt est-ce que
manon est prête
est ce que nos candidats nos candidats
sont prêtes est ce que ne peut être
qu'on va faire une bonne campagne
est ce que notre stratégie est la bonne
est-ce que je donne mon 100 pour cent t
sauf ces les affaires sur laquelle j'ai
dû contrôler puis d'ici le 1er octobre
mon intention c'est de me concentrer là
dessus sur ce matin qu'une sauvegarde
sont inscrits seuls puis si tu montes tu
es content quand t'es pas content il
sait tout et sans beaucoup savent que ce
soit le soir un risque mais le truc
c'est de la même attaque de relever à ok
ça recommence parce que sinon tu deviens
fou mais aller chaque article c'est que
l'élément critique est ce que c'est les
débats ce que c'est la chose plus
importants dont ceux d'irak ces trésors
prendre les débats c'est très important
c'est très regardée et c'était ça peut
faire une différence
mais aussi notre couverture médiatique
on va se le dire tantôt jeu lancé un peu
des fleurs au médium je vois les joies
plus les critiques et c'est clair que
les médias nous ont grande partie à leur
merci surtout pour un parti comme québec
solidaire comme le long vous donner ce
couple au moment où on se parle nous on
ne sait pas encore jusqu'à quel point
les médias vont venir dans notre autobus
de campagne en a qui nous ont dit qu'ils
viendraient d'autres qui nous ont dit
qu'ils viendraient peut-être pop est
donc une journée déjà on viendra
conclure que des médias parlent donc il
faut une décision d'interdire on en voit
dans votre besoin quand tu vois ce que
tu dis oui ça veut dire que les gens qui
écoutent c'est à dire une vérole
existeront pas ou peu ils vont ils vont
peut-être une fois quelques trucs mais
bon là car tu vois ça c'est sûr que tu
dis ouf c'est un gros pouvoir est ce que
tu sais décerne ce qui est considéré
comme une option pas considérée comme
une option
ça c'est à fall c'est sûr que ses
services avaient un petit peu à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est là que
rentre en ligne de compte les médias
alternatifs
c'est là que ça devient nécessaire
pratiquement 1 pour pallier à ce même
avec les risques ça représente mais oui
c'est histogramme fort qu'ils ont un
grand pouvoir qu'ils ont un pm toit d'un
point de vue plus personnel premières
années comme chef de parti comme un peu
vécu sur parce que tu étais déjà en laye
médiatique mais là ça devient tu viens
au centre de la cible mais si on veut
puis sa lotte le poète facile ça doit
être difficile sur plusieurs aspects
comment tout vécu cette tension là c'est
moi j'ai eu un parcours de vie assez
particulier ou à 21 ans 22 ans
sans l'avoir prévu sans que ça a été un
plan de carrière je me suis retrouvé au
quart du mouvement social enfin pressé
nord et le swing on était on était au
coeur social lascive d'énormément de
crypter soit très virulente violence
mais aussi des fois des loges
absolument j'ai naturellement été est
justement élogieux donc j'ai comme eu un
traitement de choc
ouais donc je te dirais que applications
non j'ai pas trouvé ça difficile de ma
première année de sacré dans la dette
est sous le feu de pression médiatique
puis sous un feu de critiques parce que
je les comme tellement vécu leur vie
intense et bonheur du back office
une fois que tu passes à travers ça tu
relative - cd controverse médiatique là
j'ai beau pas être vieux j'en ai vu
jamais traversé fait forcément santé
d'en relativiser les choses
santes aide à gérer la pression c'est
pas ça que je dirais que j'ai trouvé
c'est le boulot tu es je l'avais vécu
avenue puis en chambre votre impression
que la différence que tu peux faire est
plus importante que si t'es pas dans la
chambre c'est de poser ta question
une fois de temps en temps puis d'être
ainsi le où est-ce que c'est plus le
travail qui est fait en dehors d'un
charmant je verrai la vraie de faire une
bonne question est ce que c'est un
dialecte de sauve l'assemblée nationale
où les gens vraiment ses coûts de
travail des choses parce que tu es la
période des questions le bouc ou revoir
à la ccc une fraction de ce qu'ont fait
l'assemblée nationale an c'est ce qu'ont
fait le matin en arrivant c'est ça dure
45 minutes puis c'est un moment de joie
oratoire une foire d'empoigné qui des
fois donne des échanges vifs et
pertinents mais des fois donne aussi du
chômage
enfin bien plus vous voyez ce qui se
passe à la caméra son film est une chose
mais ça lance des athées ça s'envoie des
ddd pis ça s'envoie promenez vous avez
une carte c'est maintenant le cas c'est
mon tour de parler mon micro est ouvert
les croirait sur moi mais il ya 124
députés qui sont ensemble
eric rovan convois qui ont pas caméra
quoique c'est l'ocde fois le plus les
trucs les moins glorieux produisent fwi
des fois c'est une fois d'un point que
des fois c'est ça m'arrive avec manon un
mur d'eau consommée indignés par le
niveau de débats tels maxime des fois
c'est tellement ras des pâquerettes
c'est tellement des mortiers point
intéressant que ça nous arrive de se
fâcher wahyono c'est odieux que dans une
émission importante comme celle là on
est un niveau de débat aux anciens royal
mais ça ne m'émeut
mais ces moments là on s'en rappelle
parce qu'il nous faille mais c'est pas
ça l'assemblée nationale internationale
s'est aussi beaucoup d'autres choses et
des commissions parlementaires où on
travaille sur des projets de loi ou des
gens viennent témoigner de ce qu'ils
vivent
ce qu'ils veulent voir changer dans les
lois du québec il ya aussi plein
d'autres choses
ça passe pas à la télé parce que ce
point intéressant ça fait pas des clics
sur les médias sociaux parce que c'est
souvent long puis laborieux mais on est
oui on est capable de faire des petites
différences d'aller gagner des petites
victoires a lancé jean l'assemblée
nationale il ya aussi puisqu'on fait
dans nos côtés ça non plus pas la télé
intelligente un exemple moi dans mon
comté il y avait une maison personnes
âgées ou un peu plus d'une centaine de
personnes âgées d'une résidence privée
où il y avait dit une situation
inquiétante de harcèlement
d'intimidation même de 2,2 voilà de
l'exploitation des brevets des ddd
génique été négligée puisqu'ils étaient
dans une situation de détresse
ils sont venus nous voir ils sont venus
me voir à mon bureau de député avait
besoin des depuis plusieurs mois on les
aide en leur mobilisation on a réussi à
remplacer à les accompagner dans leurs
démarches pour faire remplacer
l'administration ils se sont mobilisés
on les accompagne la dame qui ont changé
d'administration de leur maison
personnes âgées maintenant ça va bien
pile j'ai rencontré des personnes qui
sont quand même vu là ils m'ont surtout
dans les brebis ont pleuré dans les bras
elle m'a qui était contente d'avoir fait
un milieu de vie sain tient peut-être
que tu vois ses enfants l'autre dis moi
ça fait pas la première page en allemand
real mais on a vraiment amélioré la
vitesse mon hobby et nous plan des gros
parce qu'ils sont et ému et content pis
nous remercient pis nous remercient dit
qui y'est je sers à quelque chose
1 même si ça passe pas ça c'est que
c'est quelque chose je qu'on entend
parler de temps en temps ce que précieux
c'est cette maison là mais ça ne
peut-être plus répandue et
l'exploitation envers les personnes
âgées
c'est quelque chose qui est c'est
quelque chose qui moi chaque fois que
j'en entends tu sais c'est que c'est
tellement pomme s'il tellement loin de
caisse que moi je ferai par exemple mais
chaque fois que j'entends ça ça me jette
à part complètement tu sais pas dans le
livre
ton livre
ouais ok la hyène gros pourcentage des
années qui ont ni amis ni connaissance
ils sont isolés compléments sont ceux
voici une des premières stations je
pense qui ouvre le livre le fait qu'on
quand on demande aux gens avez vous déjà
dans votre vie c'est le bol j'ai un peu
plus la statique examinait les troubles
en proportion importante des décennies
qui sont totalement isolés donc qui
n'ont pas d'amis c'est qu'ils ont aucun
ami aucune famille pas de conjoint pas
de conjoint il ya vraiment c'est que
c'est déjà qu'ils sont dans l'isolément
total
et quand dans ce contexte là par exemple
on va couper dans les soins à domicile
ça veut dire que le dernier petit fils
ou un filet de l'année à la société
heaven coupe et on vient de couper et sa
rampe ça fait des situations comme celle
connue dans l'immédiat ou des retrouve
des gens morts dans leurs rangs
allemands qui sont là depuis trois ans
longtemps personne norma claire seul à
remarquer qu'avec qui était disparue la
société ceci comble j'avais un livre
semences est née d'une tournée vous avez
fait à travers le québec
ouais qu'est-ce que ça allait créer pour
toi qu'est ce que ça te fait découvrir
apprendre ou qui ne savait pas déjà
peut-être je mettais beaucoup promené au
québec mais je te mettais beaucoup
promené avant pour parler
keith l'exercice de cette tournée là ça
a été de faire le tour du québec pour
écouter pour proposer des affaires pour
convaincre le monde est pour six bourses
pour les écouter me parlez nous parler
de ce qu'ils vivent et j'ai obligé dre
2-2 chose que j'ai retenu la première
c'est que les gens ont besoin par les
gens ont envie de parler de politique
le problème c'est qu'ils ont plus
d'espacé pour le faire
on leur dit en famille à table entre
amis pas politique a job on peut pas
laisser apple dit klaus a pas avoir la
technique lomé si si
qui transmet ce qui transforme la vie
des gens c'est ce qui fait que tu peux
avoir accès à une garderie ou pas c'est
ce qu'ils accédaient ce que ta grand
mère va mourir seul dans son appartement
ou avril
on va s'occuper d'elle dans un siège et
celle des dans des bonnes conditions
c'est ce qu'on va avoir une retraite les
gens de notre génération
ses seules ces chartrand qui disait si
tu t'occupes la politique américaine à
ce que toi puis la tragédie en ce moment
au québec qui dans plusieurs démocraties
c'est que les gens qui sont le plus
touchés par les décisions politiques
dans leur vie quotidienne
c'est souvent eux qui s'occupent le
monde politique les gens sur qui la
politique ont assez peu d'impact i4000
ionale 6 à des coupures dans les écoles
publiques si un découpeur dans l'aide
sociale la vie quotidienne et pas
beaucoup c'est transformé avec les gens
qui ont le lait japon dont la vie est la
moins impactés par la politique c'est
eux qui font le plus aux politiques qui
sont les plus visibles en politique
c'est un gros problème
puis moi c'est ce que j'ai remarqué en
allant sur le terrain c'est que les gens
ils sentent que la politique on n'est
pas que sur leur vie mais ils n'ont pas
d'espacé pour le parler il y donc quand
on a lancé cette initiative d'assemblées
de cuisine un peu partout au québec
on s'attendait à voir quelques dizaines
de demandes et finalement on en a eu
plus angoissant des demandes on n'en ai
pas été capable de leur c'était plus que
173 semonce en l'air est bon mais non
mais voyons les gens ont besoin de
parler les gens ont envie de parler
ils ont juste pas des espaces le c'est
là le premier truc que j'ai retenue il
faut qu'on se remette à parler de
politique
il faut qu'on se donne des espaces pour
la faire ou on en charge on en discute
11 débauche cannes postés notamment aux
débats de politique ensemble de manière
constructive on a pu c'est un sport au
québec on a perdu cette habitude
deuxième fois que j'ai retenu c'est que
malgré tout ce qu'on dit sur les
différences entre les communautés
les différences entre les régions les
différences entre les générations on
insiste beaucoup là dessus quand
généralement on parle de la société
québécoise on en parle beaucoup comme
d'une société où il ya des fractures de
génération des fractures une fracture
ville région une fracture entre les deux
souches pile
en 10 mai aps les immigrants on va tout
le temps de ses divisions là et moi même
j'étais beaucoup là-dedans et de fass
est retourné là de se promener partout
sur le territoire
elle est autant dans le grand nord que
ce plateau montréal et de rencontrer des
gens de toutes les origines puis de
toutes les régions de toutes les
communautés les âges on se dit ah malgré
tout ça malgré toutes ses divisions là
il ya encore des choses qui nous
rassemble moins l'importance accordée à
l'éducation par exemple tout le monde
nous en a parlé
l'importance accordée à l'environnement
tout le monde nous en a parlé
l'importance de revoir notre système
politique notre système démocratique
notamment par une réforme du mode de
scrutin
ce genre d'affaires la ça revenait par
tous axé leur tu vois que ok oui on se
tiraillent pommade et la zone au québec
mais si on mettait l'accent sur ce qui
nous unit le remords yola les
ingrédients d'un projet de société
intéressant mais il faut arrêter par la
politique recherchons constamment a
difficilement comme certains partis
politiques l'ont fait d'aller dans la
zone et est ce ça vient d'eux ça vient
aussi en ligne avec avec l'envi de ré
intéresser les gens politique c'est de
relancer un discours moi je reviens sur
sur le printemps arabe
on a tous vécu ensemble et ça pour moi
de mon vécu c'est la chose qui
intéressait le plus la population de
tous les âges à la politique la personne
est indifférent personne est
indifférente aux shoots l'élève peut pas
y échapper
seulement le temps de se cacher
crucke activités des gens moi j'étais
complètement agnostique à la question
politique si je me faisais pas trop ces
questions le piquant le début de la
grève d'arrivée mon premier réflexe a
été de palais en grève s'étaient c'était
une évidence et -4 pas question mais je
vais à la mecques aux femmes et enfants
avaient été payés pour nous ce n'était
pas du tout la question qu'on se pose la
question quand tu penses pas plus loin
l'évidence est que mme devant les micros
fameuse encore dit
sauf que dick ce marché un petit plus
allégations la question beaucoup plus
complexe plus
moi j'étais en faculté musée qu'elle
versait là bas on était en grève
un but quand même longtemps qui
justement c'était tellement je n'ai
jamais assisté à une assemblée de deux
facultés de piteux état les buts
allaient lâcher voter participent et
puis ça fait justement testé comme un
mouvement que les gens participent à la
politique
puis même si aujourd'hui peut-être que
les gens se sont un peu endormi mais
c'est quand même rester là en quelque
sorte qu'on a vécu ça reste le pis
surtout pas notre génération en
génération va rester marqué par ce qui
reste de lui moi je le dis je répète que
je les écris dans mon premier livre
tenir prêt puis je le répète tout le
temps pis je pense qu'au début j'avais
l'air un peu de fatigue du wishful
thinking
mais aujourd'hui les gens commencent à
inventer les gens qui ont participé à ce
mouvement le l'agent gervais qui sont
plus dans les rues à chaque semaine 1
c'est vrai oui une fois qu'on ne donne
rien dit l'essentiel et pollock et moi
je le répète depuis des années je sais
que la graine qui ont été plantés se
prétend la libye centaines de milliers
de graines chez les centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui ont été pour
poursuivre la métaphore féconde et
politiquement par ce moment là et ça
vaut pour partir ça ne partira pas puis
ça peut prendre du temps avant de se
réactiver mais ça sans dormir à papier
moi mon engagement politique je le vois
beaucoup dans la continuité 2012 que je
le vois beaucoup comme justement c'est
la responsabilité de faire vivre cet
héritage là
donner une expression politique me dire
lors quand même comme génération en 2012
on s'est découvert nous mêmes
non c'était tellement fait dire que la
politique c'est elle on s'est tellement
fait dire que nous étions des politiques
on s'occupait chose de nos petites
affaires de nos informe de nommer deux
hôpitaux on se l'était tellement fait
dire qu'on les croyait consignait
constat mis à y croire et le c'est comme
si en 2012
on s'était découvert comme génération un
découvrait que nous que les gens autour
de nous dont on au jeu dont on n'aurait
jamais pensé qu'ils seraient intéressés
par la chose politique
on sait comme on a découvert cet
internaute cette puissance le collective
et non seulement on est capable se
mobiliser clermont est capable de gagner
en 2012 on gagne quand le monde a défait
au gouvernement qui était au pouvoir
depuis dix ans est pour beaucoup de
mouvement il ya eu dans l'histoire
récente y en a pas d'autres qui ont
réussi à persuader mouvement social
c'est nous qui l'avons fait alors qu'on
était la cible d'un mépris dans la
classe politique
dans l'immédiat le physicien précédente
on ne gagne qui ce sentiment là d'avoir
été capable de faire ça ensemble
je pense moi c'est ce sentiment là que
j'ai cette fois duré aujourd'hui ne doit
y en a un impact au final on est capable
mais il faut se donner la peine
pitt au niveau personnel et ceux qui
parlent peu ton expérience parce que si
tu avais 21 22 ans j'ai eu 22 ans
pendant pendant 22 ans
mais tout semblait tellement solide
tellement préparé cet amalgame à javel
j'avais peut-être là mais j'avais pas
chantés à l'intérieur le capote est déjà
souvent les gentils quand il eut
beaucoup d'hommes ont découvert à la
télé ou dans mes entrevues et donc ça
donnait l'impression de quelqu'un de
déjà très solide qui effectue depuis
longtemps pour lui même qui a un peu
planifier ses affaires pour arriver là
et la vérité c'est que c'est un concours
de circonstances qui a fait en sorte que
je me suis retrouvé porte parole c'est
un concours de circonstances que kid et
des forces d des forces qui ont fait en
sorte que je me suis retrouvé comme
étant un début une des figures publiques
puis pendant celle la plus mise de
l'avant
pour le meilleur et pour le pire et
c'était pas un plan de carrière loti
jamais fait d'études pour faire ça je me
suis pas préparé
ça m'est arrivé et à ce moment là j'ai
une décision à prendre
je me rappelle après mon premier passage
à tout le monde en parle on est au tout
début de la grève au mois de février
je passe une première fois avec avec
souvient pierre
je me rappelle de centre avait davantage
à voir mais guillaume gillet des baux la
qualité des débats taj mahal mais pour
tout le monde et qui pense à tout le
monde en parle c'est toujours favori
rappelle les jours suivants ce ce
passage log de voir déjà ma vie commence
à changer
tandja qui commence à me reconnaître
beaucoup plus dans la rue je me rappelle
de d'être de me poser la question plus
d'avoir le sentiment d'un croisée des
chemins
alors je suis un moment où me disait à
l'époque
si je continue sa mort devenez un gros
je peux arrêter maintenant piment sauver
qu'est ce que je fais c'est bien ce
moment là j'ai fait le choix de contenu
d'y aller qui n'assume et puis je le
regrette pas mais je savais ce qui
allait venir avec c'est un choix que
j'ai faits puis gelé appris en le
faisant j'ai appris à devenir parent
parole j'ai appris à communiquer en le
faisant
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui des choses
qui sont devenus facile pour moi mais
pas parce que je dont in et vous que ce
soit parce que je vais acheter sur le
tout en faisant puis j'avais pas le
choix c'était tout débrouille tout te
planter go tt porte parole le les gens
souvent pensé qu'il y avait certains
certains sujets sur lesquels tous les
potes mouillé ou matisse à vence et pau
mais ce parce que jamais prononcé sans
voir le mans 2-2 son assemblée donc mais
est ce qui est est ce que ses positions
étaient toujours à l'adéquation avec des
positions personnelles pas
nécessairement nécessairement pas
nécessairement qu'est ce qu'on fait en
ce moment là on y va quand même où ça
aussi c'est un apprentissage c'est
l'apprentissage que la politique ce
sport d'équipé entre la politique comme
moi je la vois plus comme moi je veux la
faire sur le sport desquelles ce truc
qui se fait
groupe et que quand tu fais la politique
en groupes s'impliquent
le compromis pour notre génération des
fois c'est difficile de se dire pour
avoir un impact politique dans ma
société je vais faire le deuil
le sacrifice de peut-être certaines
préoccupations ou certaines idées qui
sont les miennes
parce que pour réunir plusieurs
personnes faut mettre tous un peu d'eau
dans son vin
c'est pour ça des fois que puis moi
c'est ce que j'ai appris en 2012 des
rockets moi je moi je
j'ai pas voté pour ça moi je l'aurais
pas fait comme ça je pense que c'est pas
la meilleure position qu'on pourrait
avoir sur un sujet ou un autre ceci
étant dit il ya un fonctionnement
démocratique
est ce que collectivement décider même
si je t'ai pas d'accord ça arrivait
aussi souvent que je m'accorde pas
d'accord tu dis bon hockey et j'ai perdu
mon débat dans mon gros je vais défendre
la décision du groupe pour le bien des
mouvements il faut que tu peux pas
autiste peut pas dire je participe à un
débat si je la gagne qui c'est ma
position qui part tout le monde fait je
vois la défense si c'est la position de
l'autre oh ben non le jeu je me retire
non pas se le dire - le deal second
débat ensemble on se donne une position
qui qu'une fois qu'on s'est donné notre
jean volatier qui moi comme porte parole
ma job à l'époque c'était de maintenir
c'est arrivé souvent que j'étais pas
d'accord puis d'ailleurs c'est ce
finalement quelques provoqué ma
démission parce que justement
j'arrive à un moment où la l'écart entre
mes positions personnelles puis celle
que je devais défendre été rendue trop
grand cet écart là existe toujours il
existe encore aujourd'hui dans mon
implication québec solidaire il ya
toujours un écart entre nos pensions
personnelles puis celle de notre groupe
dans lequel on s'est plaint que ce soit
un parti un syndicat une association
prépa l'écart existant jour juste
s'assurer qu'ils soient raisonnables le
jour et devient trop grand ben là on se
retire
mais de penser qu'on pourrait être dans
un groupe politique dans un parti
politique où on serait tout le temps à
100% d'accord sur tout c'est illusoire
parce que ça voudrait qu'on serait le
seul
dans son parti dans un pee pour ça que
des fois témoins racontent beaucoup de
jeunes qui me disait qu'avec celles
d'arte très plat je vous aime beaucoup
vous est ce dont je suis le plus proche
mais une coupe d'afrique qui me dérange
fac je prendrai pas ma carte où je ferai
pas de bénévolat soit je leur explique
du fait même mois et des affaires des
fois que je ferais différemment québec
solidaire
mais si on attend que y ait un parti
parfait pour nous fait surtout les
chronos on s'habitue à l'arrivée on va
tous avons de petits partis politiques
parti parti ph - la partie gabriel
dominique nous avons d'autres partis
mais là on n'ira pas plus loin puis
c'est sûr qu'on prendra pas le pouvoir
condamné par la politique en gagne ça
impliquera le ce que j'appelle le
sacrifice de certaines de nos petites
particularités
ça veut dire aussi qu'à l'intérieur de
notre parti on peut les défendre nos
opinions wales à convaincre le reste du
monde que cette ligne là dans le
programme on devrait la changer ça c'est
ce qu'il faut faire il faut des partis
qui permettent de faire ce permet de
dire on parle de partie mais s'apprêtent
une association ou un groupe
c'est une entreprise mais c'est de faire
le sacrifice de sa petite particularité
des fois pour travailler en ville et al
qu'ils convoquent dans une force qui
collective parce que on l'a vu en 2012
oui moi j'ai fait ce que j'ai pu en
demander bonne entrevue puis j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu en est un porte parole je
pense que la plupart des gens
reconnaissent que j'ai pas fait un aussi
mauvais travail
mais les cent mille fois la rue qui
jetait en entrevue parce qu'il y avait
cent mille personnes d'henry et mais pas
100 mille personnes dans la rue parce
que je faisais des bons entraîneurs pas
la même chose mais c'est une façon de
voir effectivement effectivement je
pense qu en ayant la halle à l'image de
la possibilité de s'associer à un parti
qui n'est pas à 100% ce qu'on croit je
pense que beaucoup de monde vont peuvent
réaliser que la politique c'est plus
pour eux est ce que serait une espèce d
illusions étudiants de toutes les
parties c'est la même chose des parties
plus tu dis moi qui est ce parce que
c'est pas tout ce que je prends mais
c'est en partie ce que je peut prôner
bain piscines
un pays tu es quand les gens disent soit
on va entendre les gens sont tous
pareils sais pas c'est pas complètement
fou non plus et que tu regardes motors
depuis 15-20 ans au québec
mais même presque une trentaine d'années
la direction générale du québec
grosso modo restée la même peu importe
les particuliers c'est ça je pense que
c'est l'aliénation pour le pour les gens
qui regardent la police a fait 15 ans
que ces deux mêmes partis aussi qu'ils
aimeraient qui a eu un bref intermède du
parti québécois puis mangé par des gens
qui ont trouvé que c'était très décevant
qu'il venait d'avoir 2012
il y avait comme un souffle à un
mouvement historique y avait une
opportunité d'aller vers des mesures
progressistes d'aller vers des mesures
pour autant et écologique t et ça a
était quoi la grande le grand geste
politique de la charte des valeurs à
l'achat de valeurs québécoises ou au
lieu de profiter du momentum pour faire
des mesures progressistes on a lancé le
québec dans un débat ultra divisif hull
3 avec le mouvement diviser les gens
selon la religion qui pratiquent selon
leur origine
et moi ça a été une désillusion est
immense parce que c'était qu'un souffle
qui venait s'abîmer dans un débat qui
était tellement de siffler pour le
québec
1 donc c'est sûr que quand tu vois ça il
est le cynisme des gens tombent pas du
ciel
oui c'est vrai que c'est on est en
hausse aussi un petit test de changement
pour apprécier retomber dans le même
gouvernement qui était pas mieux au
final ça fait que ça c'est sûr que ça ça
nourrit le cynisme des bois qui
tellement difficile à aborder le débat
identitaire steven montrer que tous les
partis où tout le monde qui touche si
brûlant typique on n'ose pas trop mais
il ya différentes notions qui sont tous
là à rassembler l'internation des
vraiment protéger la langue française
l'identité de souveraineté ou de l'autre
côté
on veut être ouverts culturel on va tout
seul puis des fois si l'enfer londres et
qui sont ici en boîte et en santé parce
que tout à fait bien unique qui les bras
trouvé c'est clair mais pour moi il ya
une chose qui est évident que la
protection du français c'est une chose
l'importance que de faire du québec un
état indépendant mois sur un projet dans
lequel personnellement je crois ce
moment c'est une chose
après ça présenter l'immigration comme
une menace
dire que les gens qui se les femmes xsl
ici nous envahissent que leur religion
nous menace menace notre style de vie où
nos valeurs c'est une autre chose c'est
pas la même chose pour moi là notre
station de protéger le français au
québec
j'en suis je suis aussi un
indépendantiste je pense que je prends
cet important l'importance de protéger
peu juste pour but de protéger de faire
cela me donne la voyez la culture
québécoise j'en suis du matin au soir
mais dire que les migrations ou la
diversité culturelle qui serait une
menace à sa lemoine ont l'eau moi je
juge joue pu parce que le québec de 2018
c'est au québec diversifier la culture
québécoise de 2018
c'est une culture diversifiée et c'est
pas deux choses la diversité culturelle
pitt identité québécoise pour moi c'est
la même chose notre identité en 2008 et
les diversifier ses essais moi ce qui
m'a fait de la peine dans le débat sur
l'achat des valeurs québécoises c'est
que ça fait pas assez des gens qui
croient l'indépendance qui croient à
l'importance de la culture et du
français pour des gens on va les autres
ses plans pour des gens intolérants à
créer dans l'esprit de beaucoup de gens
cette association là et c'est triste
parce que ce n'est pas le cas et ça fait
très très mal
au québec le fait dans cette association
l'eau fait mal au québec qu'à cohésion
sociale occupé moi j'ai l'impression
d'en
[Musique]
sur le point des différentes cultures au
québec
j'ai l'impression que ccc souvent
centrés autour du microcosme qui est
mort et al oui parce que suffixe hors de
montréal puis la diversité culturelle au
québec elles existent pas tant que ça en
tant que ça
ouais fait que quiconque a conduit
derrière des problèmes ouais exact c'est
ce qui a comparé le se commet ce serait
quoi la solution parce que moi j'avais
un super autrefois avec une mise amie
kate en francisation et lui ce qu'il dit
si le monde arrive à montréal parce
qu'ils ont juste icaunais juste montréal
oui et c'est normal les gens n'entendent
pas pape fall d'or 6 on sait que les
mesures pour attirer je prendrais sa
région parce que tu y en a mais il faut
il faut il fuir un an va plus y arrivent
ici qui parle pas tout à fait français
tu l'envoies pas à baie comeau
tu as beau il l'intégration disparaît
complètement
mais en même temps si tu intégrer le
milieu de travail il va apprendre le
français prend parfois plus vite que
site avec sa communauté qui parle c'est
ça le québec soldats ont des d une
direction pour ouais mais déjanté
reprendre ton exemple c'est un bon
exemple qui arrive qui s'enquiert au
québec qui parle peu ou pas français
c'est sûr que si tu l'envoies baie
comeau tout seul il abandonne tu peux
être sûr qu'ils vont ce soir il va soir
revenir à montréal soit même peut-être
même quitté le québec - et il y en a qui
est au québec parce qu'ils pensent que
l'intégration fonctionne pas il y en a
qui tendent à la région qui revient donc
on ne peut pas faire ça sans dire que ce
qu'on fait actuellement il ya beaucoup
de choses qu'on fait pas d'abord sur la
reconnaissance des diplômes
on ne peut pas s'attendre à ce que
quelqu'un qui est un médecin ou un
ingénieur dans sa dans son pays
d'origine et qui arrivent ici à qui on
vous appelle à vous on vous reconnaît
aucune formation complètement non
qualifiés comme c'est lé chauffeur taxi
pas demander à ces gens là après tu as
fait tu peux pas tout attendre à ce que
ces gens là soient remplies d'une énorme
et éternelle reconnaissance avant la
société québécoise est cette société là
l'accueillant disant méthyle ton
identité professionnelle
on a reconnaît pas c'est pas juste un
job un bon juste adjobi dont l'identité
une partie de ton identité parce qu'un
jean lurçat
revenir aux chantiers tête un maire dans
ton des indes été meilleurs dans dans
ton domaine
désolé c'est pas c'est un message
terriblement négative qu'on envoie quand
on dit aux à vous quand donc sur un
premier exemple deuxième exemple on dit
aux gens vous devez apprendre le
français mais on va vous donner des
cours de francisation le soir de semaine
deux heures par semaine et l'autre
membre parental que deux enfants
j'aimais voyons c'est sûr qu'elle n'en
prenons pas le français comme ça c'est
donc et on leur dit non vous vous vous
devez allez vous installer en région il
arrive en région aux réseaux ayant pas
de soutien à l'intégration c'est un
devoir partager mieux devoirs de la
personne immigrante de s'intégrer bien
devoir de la société d'accueil de france
adjoint
en ce moment on remplit pas notre bout
du livre on n'accompagne pas assez on
nous servait de francisation sont passés
sont par ailleurs assez de place les
services sont passés accessible faut
désormais plus flexible le monde puisse
y aller et on les accompagne pas en
région
ainsi on s'assure que les gens aient
accès à des aides financières aient
accès à de la francisation comme tu
disais en entreprise sur leur milieu de
travail
les gens vont s'intégrer si ce que les
gens veulent des femmes immigrantes
arrive ici prévient si pour améliorer
leur vie 1
parce qu'ils veulent travailler ils
veulent contribuer à l'économie
ils veulent que leurs enfants aillent à
l'école soit heureux soit dans une
société libre dynamique démocratique
prospère
c'est la raison pour laquelle ils
viennent s'installer ici on ne pas se
battre contre eux pour que ça arrive on
est juste besoin de lesbiennes les
intérêts j'ai l'impression que ça
pourrait aussi attaqué surtout surtout à
montréal je dois me réinstaller ce
besoin de te promener un petit peu 64e
pour réaliser la diversité mais plus
spécifiquement la pauvreté souvent oui
des diversités culturelles puis sexy
star est visible justement comme tu
disais rien qui reconnut puis tu conduis
un taxi pour une famille de quatre
tu vas trouver le temps long à montréal
tandis que si tu vas travailler
justement région où est-ce que c'est
beaucoup plus accessible ne regrettons
pas même un salaire minimum ici un
mariage c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
soutenir ce que cache coûte
non il ya aussi des beaux exemples il ya
ce fameux exemple de petits villages de
la région de québec dont le nom
m'échappe le sait
ça c'est pas d'accord mais un bon petit
village de région de québec qui a
accueilli une famille de sir y est tu
penses que c'est un village comme
quelques centaines qui une famille si
rien n'était le village des accueillis à
bras ouverts
maintenant la famille est en train de
sourire un p'tit restera seriez dans un
petit village perdu tout le village a
contribué ça a été tu es une intégration
magnifique ces gens là sont devenus des
amis de la moitié du village est ainsi
possible c'est possible le québec c'est
ça aussi
1 d'accord on je pense que c'est tout
c'est tout pour le temps que keita avec
nous et ça a été très intéressante
discussion
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de têtes
de prêter à notre podcast c'est
important de parler de sa famille c'est
le fait d'avoir le temps de la
exactement exactions on est souvent dans
le monde des médias pris dans des
formats de trois minutes pour d'autres
messages ces jeunes et d'avoir le temps
de jaser fbi excellent merci beaucoup
merci messieurs bonne chance dans la
campagne on travaille fort
[Musique]